it's time for a rap battle we haven't
done this for a couple weeks and we got
some really good submissions oh yeah
first how come no black guys submit well
we initially called it white rappers
only so oh but what about will my boy
Dustin Poirier submits Tony Ferguson
coming up saying dude you back on
cocaine of the diamond yes I don't think
you're gonna give him that fight I don't
think they're I think they I don't think
didn't do the fight at all yeah it's
[ __ ] stupid
dude I was watching some Tony Ferguson
highlights oh wow have you never seen
him I've never seen it oh it's like he
it's like yes it's like his feet are
like knives made it's like he's like
it's crazy ain't nobody want to short
fight that boy in short no that's crazy
oh well the diamond goes in right I'm
telling you nobody wants to fight that
manager but that's the thing about the
diamond and I'm telling you because I
know what your show it's a bad idea it's
a great I'm not saying it's the best
idea but I'm saying that because he
needs a full camp if you give diamond a
full camp all right now we're talking
but short notice
it's in two weeks because weren't even
training right oh yeah right to fight
Kebede right he's a good chance to beat
kabir yeah it's the best short notice
some of you [ __ ] yeah row and it would
be Tony Ferguson let's roll I just got
to go with that I just think I agree
with you yeah but you I know what's a
hangout tiger so so last week with rap
battle we had I yes music he was the
bigger gentleman with Flo who said some
inappropriate things about Kat oh yeah
oh yeah Johnny see the angry bald
gentleman who said the n-word 58 percent
42 percent I forgot the heels making
t-shirts they were hats and there were
only two of them that got bought and
that was years ago did sell out years
ago years ago he sold out of n hat but
they use it in the Asian community chin
you guys use it all the time the n-word
Koreans do but not that's not what it
means it's not black people
it's just [ __ ] and [ __ ] yeah and what
is it no two wishes you [ __ ] me it
sounds so bad but that's just the way it
is it's crap I don't beat you up I
yeah and I'm not surprised you guys say
it dude I see how you guys it's Mexicans
and say it to every now and then yeah
imprisoned Mexicans will say it all the
time and I think once you get into
prison dude you can make choices you're
already in prison yeah it's only gonna
get worse
how low can you go you know yeah I
always get a tattoo if I go to president
says I do not say the n-word on my bed
yeah just right out the gate and then in
the parenthesis unless you do well I
don't say it first
bro that's my role let's get into this
episode so then of course little brows
beat is music 83% oh yeah to 17% but we
got some really really good submissions
I can [ __ ] with little brows oh I I
honestly believe it oh wow wow it must
be real man because you know put your
mother on you think you can put your
grandmother on it Nick we could do a
little duet probably put put is y'all
know if I quit
don't do that guys please don't do that
I know you would for the love of the
show but don't do that to my mom don't
make it don't I know she's boarding
house writing to help but don't make her
do yeah she's not that bored she does
not deserve that all right what do we
got here yeah big gracias gracias
you should look denelle
Gang Gang buzz-buzz the solder hastily
conforto all right Pete Sun vici bro
Haywood have a rap for the king of the
rats and big brown in the bag bee sting
in that ass like a prison visit making
chin behind glass that corner looking
bad ethnic I think I love you cast I
fell in love and now I'm changing my
ways I've been on pornog for like 70
days ain't a mullet this a hockey
haircut
Brendan slicked back looking like a
Snuggie there's much in estate the best
place to shoot roids idiots on the
Coleman taking like cro cop mini eights
that third round punch saving up my
money I got 48 hon sin allows dual here
we come black blowing 3o Meg Ryan mix
with Wang Chung Brendan beef price gum
Derek's Morgan Freeman son Nick looking
like he's never seen the Sun the Patels
an urban version of Kirsten Dunst and it
is like a clearance monkey cat you are
the one now let's lose these legs
Highway 190 me - Tiffany lane yeah don't
be grounded you got that CTE so we gotta
drop a verse to for you will de nada
here we go little nothing about this
fella
nothin looking
[Music]
when it comes to it's weird they decide
to shoot the whole thing in front of a
golden crown real production my face
back together
definitely more entertaining I don't
know if it [ __ ] a little browse though
I don't know I'd have to go back in and
listen to that like I'll do it after but
not to go back in and listen to that
again and there's so much in there what
the fans decide but that's pretty a
culture buff I can't
Earvin Kirsten bring it off Oh beautiful
yeah yeah you guys are both beautiful
people that's spider-man's girl Doug
yeah had a black spider-man what would
that be Hollis can be you
Miles Morales oh wow well he's black in
Puerto Rican right you talked about the
cartoon yeah spider-man verse
mm-hm yeah there was that big movement
to get childish gambino at one point
yeah you're supposed to but
haters I hit myself
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
like just crew is that boy the white man
no boy the guests sure like he looks
like he's something more than just yeah
there's something else going on there
well they look like beautiful young
people men are beautiful young they're
you know these are young men and women
it looks more like chins race than you
know yeah you can't even you gotta
that's not that's it dude Asian people
and white people look different than
each other Brendan he looks he looks
like Theo than me no he looks like chin
but with sammy sosa lotion like he's
really white look like chins face and
facial hair he looks pretty I mean he
looks like a white guy to me look like a
decent white behind is he white and
outdoors probably at some time the rest
of his squad is white maybe he is and I
like when they came in with that crispy
hitter with the mask right there dude
like Nellie's boy yeah oh that's like
Nellie's little buddy [ __ ] uh what
were they call masks a dactyl that
always showed up the st. lunatics
yeah it's one had a mass one had the
[ __ ] band-aid yeah wasn't terrible
Weiser that's what they're called mm-hmm
the heading was good and that's somehow
some video hoes to both them are those
the only two Nick I heard it for this
week I mean we have week we could do
this an entire episode we got submission
well I give to you your raps no geez
yeah what do you guys think cat chin
it's to me that it's different than the
little browse little browsers like
straight up like rat battle this is like
more production editing like I think lil
brows has a video coming with his he did
that remix version and on Friday he's
trying to get back in the studio and do
a video for it so there's more common
but yeah I don't know we've kind of
really built up lowbrow so I think we
were like influence some of the voting I
think his talent does it too though yeah
a little browse betta I remember I've
woken up in the middle of the night and
had a little brow [ __ ] going on in my
head yeah my stand up I walk out the
little Browns remix damn crowd goes
Krunk they do yeah but these guys are
these I thought that that both of these
are really great both these are really
good I just feel like they're different
it's more like these two are competing
against each other then little browse
that first one might be my favorite
actual song of the whole time like it'd
just so many references that go way deep
into both show they're both so good both
of the great shout to both yeah I don't
even know what to think or say or do
anything won't work it's a lot of work
to do those yeah it's just amazing that
these guys that these guys and girls did
this well the girls kind of sat down had
a good time but thank you Kirsten
[Music]
the king nothing
[Music]